احمد بحضرتك
30 سنوات على اخر عرض في مدينه عدن تعود
العروض المسرحيه الى المدينه التي تشهد
تعافيا ثقافيا واستقرارا امنيا
رغم المعاناه التي خلفتها حرب ميليشيات
الحوثي
ين
في اليمن اختارت هذه الكنيسه التي تعود
الى زمن الاستعمار البريطاني لتقدم فيها
تجربه مسرحيه فريده
لاداء المسرحيه فيه بسبب الرئيسيين الاول
هو ان الطراز المعماري للمبنى يتوافق مع
الحقبه الزمنيه والاحداث التي كتبها
شكسبير في دوله اوروبيه مختلفه واطراز
المعماري المبنى هو معروف انه بني في ايام
العدل
الاستعمار البريطاني الشيء الاخر هو ان
همم مجلس الشريعي تعرض للتدمير الجزئي
خلال حرب 2015 ونحن فرقه حريصين دائما على
موضوع الاثار والتراث فقلنا انه لماذا لا
نعرضها في في المجلس التشريعي ونكون حافز
من اجل همم
المركز الثقافي البريطاني مسرحيه هامل
شهيره الكاتب البريطاني واللي يمشي كسبير
التي تؤدى للمره الاولى في اليمن اختارت
الفرقه تقديم المسرحيه باللهجه العدنيه في
تج جديده المسرح كان في عدم يعني وقد
طبيعه خاصه اما الان مع الظروف الحرب
تاثرت كل شيء كل كل الحياه
الفن والحياه المعيشيه وكل شيء
تعرضوا المسرحيه في عدن على مدى نحو عشره
ايام
مجددا الفن المسرح في هذه المدينه التي
تعاني من تراجع ثقافي الى حد الشلل كما
يعيد عرض هذه المسرحيه الحياه للمسرح
العدني لتدب الحياه في عروقها حيث كانت
رائده في هذا النوع من الفنون خلال عقود
طويله ويعود اول عمل مسرح عرض في عدن الى
العام
1905 عدن هي سباقه في جميع المجالات في
المجال المسرح الرياضي وايضا السينمائي
لكن نتيجه الحرب طبعا حصل اللي حصل ولكن
اليوم تستعيد مكانتها
وهيبتها من جديد في مؤشرين اخر على تعافي
المدينه تعد عدن دبيب الحياه الى خشبات
مسارحها على طريق السعاده رياداتها في
مجالات الفني والمسرح رد فان دبيس العربيه
عدل